Nha là đạo đã bày tổ vui mừng trước sự phát triển mạnh mẽ và tốt đẹp của quan hệ sông phương.
Tổ mi thứ tổ lâm và tổng thống đồn à chăm.
Phan ngành việc hai ngoài đam phản của hai nước đã thống nhất quên bố chung về tàm phó kỳ
về khuôn khổ hiệm định thương mại đối ứng, công bằng và cân bằng.
Tổng thống đồn à chăm, lấy gần gần nằm, cam kết, dành quyền tiếp cận tị trường in đái cho hàng phó ác của phó kỳ
trong đó có xeu tổ bật của lớn.
Ởng khẩn định, phó kỳ sẽ cách giảm đám kệ, tối đối ứng trong nhiều hàng quá sức cầu của Việt Nam
và sẽ cấp tục hợp tác với Việt Nam trong giả quyết những vướng mắt anh hưởng đến quan hệ thương mại sông phương.
Nhất là trong các liết vực mà hai bên yếu tiền.
Tổ mi thứ tổ lâm đề nghỉ phó kỳ sớm công nhận Việt Nam là kinh tế thị trường và bỏ hàng trẻ sốt cầu
đối với một số mặt hàng công nghệ cao.
Tổ mi thứ tổ lâm và tổ thống đôn anh trong cũng đã chào đổi một số phương lớn
Việt phó kỳ lớn, túc lại quan hệ đối tác chiến lược quan dẹ chòng những nặp tới.
Hai nhá lễ đạo, đã thung qua việc păng cường chào đổi đoạn, tiếp xúc cơ cao và cắt cấp
để mạnh hợp tác trong các liết vực kinh tế thương mại và đầu tư.
Đặc biệt trong các liết vực có ý nghĩa Canjoch, độc phá, nhiều quà học, công nghệ cao.
Nhân dịch này, tổ mi thứ tổ lâm nhất lại lời mời tổ thống đôn anh chăm và phương nhân thăm Việt Nam
và bây tò mong muốn sớm gặp lại tổng thống chăm trong thời gian tự.
Tổng thống chăm trên trọng cảm ơn lời mời của tổ mi thứ và bây tò mong muốn sớm gặp lại tổ mi thứ.